>> Fantastic. Now the preDrawCache function has some tricky math that we'll go
ahead and walk through here. The first thing we'll need to do is determine the
number of canvases that we're going to use along the x and y-axis. To do this,
we actually divide the entire pixel size by the canvas tile size and then floor
the value. Note that we add the 1 here to round up, ensuring that any pixels
that fall outside of this division operation are actually covered and added to
our canvas. From there, we do a simple 2-dimensional for loop that walks through
and creates a new canvas tile and set the x and y values equal to the position
of x offset times tile size. Once that's done, we simply concatenate this new
canvas tile to the already created array. And then, we set fully loaded equal to
true.